هذه خطوة تصعيدية مهمة جدًا،
وهي في بعض النواحي هي ما كنا
نقلق بشأنه خلال الأسابيع القليلة الماضية
وإلى حد ما خلال
الشهرين الماضيين حيث
كان يُنظر دائمًا إلى الضحايا منا على أنهم خط أحمر.
في كل هذه الهجمات
التي رأيناها على مصالحنا المختلفة، هناك
إصابات طفيفة، هناك أشخاص
مستهدفون لم يكونوا في الواقع
مواطنين أمريكيين، هذه هي نقطة التحول، لذا فإن
مقتل ثلاثة جنود أمريكيين أمر مهم،
فهي ليست بالضرورة نقطة تحول
إلى  تصعيد غير منضبط بين
الولايات المتحدة وإيران لكنها
خطوة أخرى خطيرة للغاية لأنه كما أقول،
سيتعين على الولايات المتحدة الرد
بقوة أكبر مما فعلته مع
الهجمات السابقة أم هذا يعني احتمال قتل
بعض قادة الميليشيات العراقية الكبار جدًا
وربما بعض كبار الإيرانيين أه
وهذا سيشكل معضلات لكل من
أم بغداد وتان للرد بدوره أه
فيبدو أن هذا الهجوم
نفذته مجموعة تطلق على نفسها اسم
المقاومة الإسلامية في العراق وهي
ليست مجموعة حقيقية هذا اسم
تم استخدامه من قبل أم مختلفة  ميليا أه
الميليشيات الإيرانية التي تميل إلى أن
تكون عراقية ولكنها تعمل أيضًا في سوريا وكانت
تستخدم هذا الاسم أثناء
صراع غزة حيث كثفت
هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار أم والهجمات الصاروخية على
المصالح الأمريكية أم سابقًا ردت الولايات المتحدة
بالاستهداف  كبار القادة
بقتل أعضاء المجموعات الذين
كانوا على وشك شن هجمات
لذا يجب أن يكون هذا تصعيدًا
من ذلك وهذا أمر خطير للغاية لأسباب ليس
أقلها أن هذه المجموعات هي
رسميًا جزء من أجهزة الأمن العراقية
وبالتالي يمكن ذلك  لا يتم ذلك
دون تدخل الدولة العراقية
أه لكنهم بالتأكيد مدعومون من إيران
وتدعمهم إيران طوال
الطريق أ أؤكد أنهم
جهات فاعلة مستقلة من حيث أنهم لا
يعتمدون بالضرورة على إيران بشكل يومي
الأموال أم أنهم يحصلون على بعض ذلك من
الدولة العراقية لأنني أقول إنهم جزء من الدولة
العراقية ولكن الدولة العراقية
بالتأكيد لا تسيطر عليهم،
فالأرجح أنهم سيسيطرون جزئيًا على
الدولة العراقية أم لذا فإن إيران تقف
وراءهم  لكنها لا تتخذ
قراراتهم اليومية نيابةً عنهم. إيران لا تريد
صراعًا مفتوحًا مع الولايات المتحدة أم
وستفعل كل ما في وسعها على ما أعتقد لتجنب
ذلك ولكن في نفس الوقت لا
يمكنها تحمل أه عدم إنشاء قواتها الخاصة
الردع الخاص، لذلك إذا كانت هناك
هجمات كبيرة، فسيتعين عليها الرد بطريقة ما، ونحن
نمضي قدمًا أكثر فأكثر في
المنحدر الزلق، وليس من
الواضح بالضرورة بعد أن هجوم الطائرات بدون طيار هذا،
على عكس جميع هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار الأخرى،
كان من المفترض أن يقتل الولايات المتحدة.
ربما كان الافتراض هو أن
الدفاعات الجوية ستتدخل، لكن الهجمات
أصبحت أكثر خطورة
خلال الأسابيع القليلة الماضية ولهذا السبب
كنا
قلقين.